members i think we are ready to start
okay
okay good evening uh members and
officers of the council and also members
of the public who've joined us this
evening for this meeting of the overview
and scrutiny penalties the 30th of
august 2022 and you are very welcome
the fire alarm procedures should the
alarm be activated please vacate the
offices down the main staircase opposite
the lifts in the foyer assemble in
hawley square on the green and officers
will assist you and advise you when it's
deemed safe to return to the chamber
would everyone please ensure their
mobile phones are turned to silent and
they are not used to communicate phone
calls or any other means whilst this
meeting is in progress unless you're
filming of course
please note that this meeting is being
live streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
okay thank you very much we can
skip over that bit then we have some
members who have asked to speak under
rule
20.1 they are counsellors bailly
ghana smith and councillor yates
are there any more members here who wish
to speak
under rule 20.1
sure
i'm not sure
[Music]
on agenda item number five i take it and
indeed
[Music]
certainly council rayford
you're very welcome
now i have not received any requests for
public speaking
at this meeting but
i do intend with members permission to
ask if there are any members of the
public
who would like to address
the meeting
no right thank you very much you're
welcome to attend and see how we do
things
is
i'll tell you what i'm going to do it's
very unusual because normally you would
speak on something that relates to
yourself but since you are representing
an organization
may i with your permission ask the
counselors to speak first
and if their questions have not covered
your topic i'll come back to you if they
have you can then say
that the points have been answered or
dealt with or mentioned okay
just a month thank you very much
i take it that's okay yeah thank you
thank you
okay the agenda item proper then
apologies for absence we have apologies
from council of ratigan who is
substituted by councillor right
there she welcome thank you for coming
and i think that's it the rest of us
were all here
are there any declarations of interest
members wish to make
no okay and now then we move on to the
minutes
of the previous meeting on the 21st of
july a copy is of course as always
attached
uh to the agenda for members to see
um i just have a short review to bring
you that
the stagecoach decision to discontinue
bus some bus service routes in senet
officers sent invitation emails to
stagecoach and no response back was
received an invitation was also sent to
the kcc cabinet member
responsible for transport
and no response was received
the joint transportation board chair
advised that she had engaged stagecoach
and kcc in discussions and that an
update would be brought back to the
channel could be brought back to this
panel once those
discussions have been concluded
quick update there on that
item so as regards the minutes
yes counts again thank you i think it's
very disappointing that stagecoach
weren't able to engage more directly
with us about something so important to
our residents but also i'm pleased to
hear that we're going to get some kind
of feedback do you have any time scale
for their review
yet
microphone was off that was for
recording purposes
um
i will write thank you for your comment
i will write and ask for a written
update uh in due course as soon as
possible so how they're actually
operating the system now and what
changes may or may not be able to be
made if that if that answers your your
point okay thank you cancer king so with
regards to the minutes then and that
additional point
can i have a proposal for the minutes
thank you councillor thompson and a
second to please
thank you very much councillor colin
cook
we're moving on then to agenda item
number four the approval of net zero
strategy and the action plan for public
consultation
council bayford
yeah thank you chairman are there any
words you wished to add
only a very few
um i think the object of the exercise
this evening is quite straightforward
you've got in front of you the net zero
strategy you've had it for a little
while and you've got the report that
goes with it which gives you some
background to it and
if you like highlights the the major
points
this strategy has been some time in the
making
thanks to dr scott here i think we've
got now a very superb document very
detailed and i think members should be
aware that at each stage along the way
this has gone to the cabinet advisory
group for climate emergency and their
approval has been sought and in fact
they've approved the complete document
it's also been um two corporate
management team
who've approved it and it's also been to
cabinet cmt so it's here tonight for you
to
hopefully approve it to go forward to
cabinet um for us
as a council to adopt it and then to go
out to you can't use the word
consultation now i'm not sure what the
word is engagement you can go out to
public engagement which we'd like to do
and obviously we're interested in any
comments that you've got if you think
there's anything that's been missed or
needs adding
i would just stress though that if you
talk about amendments
that might have the effect of delaying
the strategy being produced and
obviously we're aware that the emergency
is getting more and more critical so
it may well be that if you've got any
suggestions for any changes that we
maybe take them on board and sort of
come back with sort of amendment a later
stage um other otherwise you know if it
means delaying the strategy i don't
think that would be good but thank you
chairman and we're here to answer any
call
hannah's here to answer any questions
you've got
thank you very much uh council bayford
well members we have the the pack before
us
um
we are asked to comment on and make any
recommendations as councillor bayford
has said we will be
asking cabinet to agree the following
that the cabinet approves the proposed
amending wording if there is any and
that the cabinet approves the strategy
that's it in brief so comments members
please
counselor austin
thank you chair um i'd like to
congratulate hannah and anybody else
involved in this it's it's an excellent
document very impressed with it i've got
loads of questions but probably i'll
leave some of those just to email to
hannah the first comment i wanted to
make and i'm sorry it's a negative
because it's nothing to do with with
hannah's work but i do feel really
strongly in terms of governance that
this should have gone out as well as all
the consultation that you've mentioned
council bathroom this should have gone
out to all councillors before it went on
to a public agenda because we've we've
got people saying to us you know what's
happening with this this strategy we've
seen it on the agenda et cetera et
cetera et cetera because we're on this
group we know about it because our
colleague is on the cag we know about it
but if i was not involved in this i
wouldn't have known it had happened and
i think that's that's remiss of us i
think we should get into a habit now of
making sure that we allow time for all
councillors to receive a document as
important as this before it it goes out
into the public domain
my questions are mostly about how we can
be a bit
tougher on some of the requirements that
we make of ourselves and of our partners
i think most particularly looking at the
areas where we've only got partial
control
whether there are ways that we can
make
stronger requirements of our contractors
make stronger requirements on our
projects i'm thinking about some of the
projects that are happening at the
moment that we're involved in one way or
another for example the leveling up work
on ramsgate port
which is likely to have quite a negative
effect i would have thought and some of
the other things in which we are in in
some more distant way involved like
parkway station likewise
and i'm also thinking about
development the work we do with
developers
and the number of new estates that we're
seeing springing up a long way away from
public transport etc what kind of
influence we think we might have there
via planning regulations those are the
kinds of things that that concern me
about this but i do think it's a really
excellent document and thank you for
producing it
um there's probably a couple of things
that we can do
within procurement around
making stronger requirements on
contractors um and so i'll be working
the procurement team around that and
putting that into the procurement
strategy so at the moment we've just got
five percent waiting
um but as we move forward in a fair way
we'd be putting more weight on companies
that are larger than companies that are
smaller so we need to do that in a fair
way
um
and then obviously you know as things
become clearer how we can start to put
net zero aims within projects and within
policies and things like that so we're
hoping that you know as things move
forward we can we can start to put all
of those things in place thank you
thank you i also think it's a brilliant
document as well so so thank you to
everybody who's had an input whether
they were
part of a working party or not but he's
very welcome
i i support uh
what council austrian said about
procuring maybe maybe the towel can wag
the dog if we can we can adjust that
waiting then when maybe we can force
some of the big
the big the big
companies we use to provide us with
stuff
to to reduce reduce
move back to 2030 rather than 2050 so i
suppose it's using the power that we
have in purchasing that is a good idea i
also want to ask is it a dynamic
document so in terms of the carbon
emissions will we be reviewing those as
various things on the horizon appear i
note that we look at our own carbon
emissions which is great but then the
vast carbon emissions across the whole
area of sanit are to do with
other big organizations particularly the
the nhs
on our horizon we obviously have the
developments at the port which could
could increase carbon emissions from the
poor which directly relate to us but
also we have manson appearing on the
horizon with its own massive carbon
emissions so as we move forward and a
lot of these projects come online
there's also parkway station which is
another carbon emission
as we move forward we would be building
or reviewing the carbon emissions not
just of our own but also of the big of
the big
events that go on around us
i also i also wanted to say one of the
things that i find really difficult as a
resident trying to reduce my own carbon
emissions is what exactly can i do so
it's how do we as a council try and
impart that information to residents we
obviously have a captive
a captive number of a small number of
residents in our own social housing so
it would be pretty easy to to to try and
influence those households and hopefully
save money
but what what what how how can we
influence our individual residents in in
thanat to do their bit to
reduce our carbon emissions
and that's all i've got to say but thank
you thank you for this
thank you very much councillor wing
okay sorry chairman can i just answer a
couple of points on that yes um i mean i
think the first answer is that we will
keep it under review obviously
um and uh as far as what individuals can
do there's a section in the strategy
which tells people more and i'm sure
there's going to be more educational
things that are going to be done um
obviously resources the usual cry you
know lack of rather than anything else
as far as review is concerned i don't
know if you noticed it but we've
actually said in there that right from
the start we set up a regular review so
in fact myself hannah and chris blundell
who's the corporate director responsible
for the environment we we meet on a
monthly basis to review the detailed
action plan so though you've got actions
in the report there is a detailed action
reaction plan which says who's doing
what and when and where and so monthly
that is going to be reviewed so
hopefully it won't slip like other
projects around the council in the past
might have done you know so we'll be
looking at it constantly so i hope that
gives you some kind of confidence that
thank you i think the other thing i
wanted to bring up is how do we make
this the document become part of the way
the council thinks
in other areas so planning is a
particular area where we desperately
need to review
our planning particularly in relation to
buildings in our conservation zones and
enabling some slippage maybe on on
planning regulations which which stops
for example grade two listed buildings
having having double glazed wooden sash
windows that nobody would notice from
from the streetway so how can we build
how can this pervade our thinking not
only as a council but as individual
residents
maybe that's the key to
making this document work because it's a
very fine document
i mean i think one of the ways is that
we from this point on we bang the drum
about it as loudly as we can i mean it's
got exposure already in some places it's
going to actually go to cabinet it's
then going to go out to engagement
whatever that might be
but i mean and the other thing is that
if you looked at the detailed action
plan you would see that sort of every
department in the council is involved in
some way so everybody's aware of it
everybody's going to be held to account
where that's possible
and
you know
i think it's just by going on about it
almost endlessly which is what we need
to do and certainly we intend to do that
so hopefully you'll join us
is okay to add just one uh one point so
uh the action plan um or the
on uh i don't know if you've got page
numbers but on priority four addressing
emissions in decisions and projects
there's an action which is to add
climate change as a consideration and
sign off in all capital reports
so that's how it will infiltrate every
action within the council
and with regards to engagement we're
going to start off in green week we've
got two events planned eco days
so we'll start off the engagement
during that week as well
thank you
thank you it is a great report very
pleased to see it my question is is
really quite specific and that was
i was very pleased to
read about the installation of heat
pumps but it did say we would have to
approach the public sector
decarbonisation fund
because we wouldn't have the funding to
do that ourselves so my question was
have we done that or if not when will we
do that
and also i was also very pleased to see
about looking at using the risk
management reserves to make sure we have
enough staff staff to apply for the
funding because that often is a hurdle
for us when we are not particularly well
staffed for those kind of projects thank
you
thank you very much
thank you very much chair and thank you
for the question so um yeah we've done
quite a lot of work in the
housing revenue account
with consultants looking at the
potential cost of decarbonisation of the
housing stock
and the resources we've got for things
like heating upgrades insulation
upgrades and structural works
fall quite a long way short of the
overall cost of net zero targets for
2035 so we know that we've got to bid
for external resources
there is an opportunity coming up in
wave two for the social housing
decarbonisation fund this autumn
and we are currently working with
consultants
to help put together a bid to be
submitted during wave 2.
we're also working on
a strategy document specifically
for the housing stock which does
uh sit within this overall strategy and
and hannah has worked very closely with
the housing team to make sure that the
two documents are compatible
and and the principles within that
document are the um
and it will come here for review anyway
in the next couple of months
but the the overriding principles are
that we tackle the worst housing stock
first
that
we
deal with the fabric of buildings before
first effectively improving insulation
before changing heating systems
and also uh that we um
something that would be recommending
around what we've called no regrets
which means you know we don't rush off
and install untested
um technology we make sure that we put
find the right solutions for the right
buildings
so putting all that together
we've we've also got already currently
got an approved capital program for
working on our
um tower blocks
refurbishment about our blocks we know
that they're the worst performing
buildings that we have
and our
wave 2 bid
is most likely to be put together
around improving improving the thermal
efficiency and heating systems in the
tower blocks
just well sorry just while i've got the
my microphone on i i wondered if um
councils would like um just a little
response about the question about
planning
um so um within the agreed uh
scope of the review of the local plan
and set out in the low in the agreed
local development scheme
the scope of that review does include a
response to the council declaring a
climate emergency
and so when the um when the local plan
comes forward
um for consideration and obviously
there's a there's a statutory
consultation process attached to that
and there'll be opportunity for members
to discuss those issues um
then you know there will be an
opportunity to talk about how planning
can contribute to this agenda
one more quick i'm on medication
thank you um i wondered to what extent
we were working uh sharing good practice
with other councils on this i was
thinking about waste freighters because
i'm perfectly sure i've heard from swale
that they've managed to save money on
electric freighters by some kind of
combination of lease and
conversion or something but i'm just
wondering whether we you know what
contacts we've got with other councils
and what we're learning from them and
they're learning from us
yeah sure so um i'm part of the climate
change um
it's called the climate change network
group so all of the officers all the
climate change officers come together um
every couple months and so we exchange
ideas and new things moving forward and
then obviously there's kmeg as well
which is coming down from kcc
and just the other week
councillor bayford and i met with
councillor susan carey and so there's
going to be more linked up work with kcc
as well going forward which is great
news
just on the waste vehicles because
you've raised this before i mean big
problem we've got apart from the fact
that electric vehicles are about twice
the cost of the other ones is the fact
that ours still have quite a long life
in them so in fact i mean we're under
constant review and looking at what's
going on because um one thing that we're
hopeful of in the waste and recycling
area is that there will be technological
improvements and that there will be
better more economic solutions coming in
the future so the fact that we not doing
it right away we couldn't if we wanted
to but fact we're not doing it may prove
to be a blessing in disguise that's my
take on it anyway
uh thank you everybody very much i want
to turn to mr blundell in just a moment
but i need to beg your indulgence
this medication is a serious pain um
thank you very much members and also
members of the public thank you for
allowing the interruption uh we'll
reconvene the meeting then and i'm going
to turn please to mr blundell
thank you chair um i just wanted to
address council austin's first
comment about the publication of the
information i think we should always
do whatever we can to engage with
members um throughout the process
in terms of the strategy there was a
notification that went out in the loop
it was probably at the same time as the
publication was processed which
the agenda was published which is not
i can understand
ideal
but
members throughout the council will have
had access to the strategy regardless if
they're on scrutiny or not
thank you very much then uh for all
those comments members we are asked to
recommend the proposed net zero strategy
to cabinet for decision do members agree
agree thank you very much
so we move on then to agenda item number
five and before i ask councillor
whitehead to present her call for action
requests
i'd just like to share with members
the advice best advice and the process
we have
for looking at this matter
there are three options cited in this
covering report
which are
the panel could opt to debate the call
for action
and agree to conduct a full hearing at
an agreed future panel meeting
members could choose to debate the call
for action request and make
recommendations
to be considered by cabinet
and three
members could opt
not to debate the call for action and
therefore
decide to take no further action
with reference to the options in
paragraph three of the report that you
have
members guidance is sought on how to
progress
this call for action should be should
that be the case
and members are also asked to note that
a wider report on housing delivery will
be considered by cabinet at its meeting
on the 22nd of september
that clearly is not a report that's
happened overnight it's been some time
in the preparation and deliberating and
producing of that report
so we need to consider
panel as we hear this call for action
whether we would be satisfied
that all reasonable attempts have been
made to resolve the issue
by the councillor bringing
the call for action
do the responses received by the
referring councillor
demonstrate that the matter is not being
properly processed
progressed i beg your pardon
has this panel i think the answer to
that one is no has this panel considered
a similar issue
recently
we did but on a slightly different topic
if i'm if my memory serves
is there a similar or related issue
which is the subject of a review on
current scrutiny program i don't think
there is
have all relevant service areas or
partner organizations been informed
and been given enough time to resolve
the issue
what responses
has the counsellor received
is this a case that should be pursued
via the council's corporate complaints
procedure
does it relate to a quads quasi-judicial
matter
or decision such as planning or
licensing
is this issue part of an individual's
own
personal agenda
any issue
raised should be one
of genuine local concern and have an
impact on the local community
is this
an issue currently
being looked at by another form of local
scrutiny authority e.g kent
county council
i guess we could include well except for
the word local we could include the
government in that because i'm sure the
government are considering this
all the time
and as with all scrutiny does the matter
referred
have the potential for scrutiny to
produce recommendations which could
realistically be implemented
and lead to improvements for anyone
living or working in the referring
members
ward
so just some points and i'm happy to go
back to those at any point that might be
required a bit later on
counselor benny
thank you good evening
um
i always find it a bit awkward going
first before the uh gender item but i'll
just say what i i feel
um i just wanted to say a few brief
words in support of council whitehead's
call for action
homelessness in thanet really is a
matter of growing concern and it's not
just in margate either
i received many more emails now than i
used to as well as seeing many many
posts on social media from people
desperately looking for accommodation
especially accommodation that's
affordable
the cost of private rents has
skyrocketed well beyond the pockets of
many of our residents and the
availability of rental accommodation is
diminishing in part due to the rise of
second home buyers and the growth of
airbnbs and other such platforms
with the lack of any substantial rollout
of centrally funded social housing it's
mainly left to planning authorities like
ours to negotiate with private
developers to provide
social housing instead
in thailand developers are required to
provide 30 of affordable housing on
larger developments consequently in
order to gain to gain a provision of 500
affordable houses there will be a
corresponding build out of more than a
thousand market priced houses
with plenty of wriggle room to reduce
the affordable housing quota if the
development is not deemed viable enough
the other big issue as i mentioned
earlier is the increasing trend for
private landlords to evict long-standing
tenants in favor using their properties
for short-term holiday laps in order to
make a faster buck
this has happened to at least two blocks
of flats within a stone's throw of where
i live with up to a dozen tenants being
displaced through no fault of their own
and having to chase fewer and more
expensive properties
in addition properties being snapped up
by city workers who who post covered are
able to work from home and have been
attracted to sanit where they can buy
more for their money and use the good
transport links to london
there's nothing wrong with that but it
all adds to the mix
and also the final well another thing
that adds to the mix is the resurrected
right to buy scheme which will only
further deplete the existing social
housing struck
so all these factors
are legislated for a government
government level but as a councillor who
is seeing these problems on a day-to-day
basis i really do think think that
something needs to be done to level the
playing field for everyone
therefore i support this call for a
councilwide strategy whether that be
lobbying the government or some other
way to try to draw the attention to this
increasingly dire situation
thank you
thank you council bailey councillor
ghana
thank you
uh yeah i'd also like to
start by thanking councillor whitehead
for
submitting this call to action with
regard to the rising eviction numbers
for low-income households and the
associated homelessness
this is something that is impacting
residents as has been said across the
whole of the district and it's certainly
a subject worthy of a call to action
especially as we know with the
approaching rise in energy prices things
are only going to get worse
i've personally been on a steep housing
learning curve since i was elected three
years ago and i've unfortunately become
more and more familiar with section 21
eviction notices
since then of
affecting both people in my ward of
saint peter's and as we mentioned across
the rest of broadstairs
number of people being evicted through
no fault of their own some with young
families has increased sharply over that
period while at the same time it has
become more difficult to find new rental
properties available at a reasonable
rent
for some this has meant having to move
into tempe accommodation often outside
planet and remote from any support
networks and despite the best efforts of
officers and cabinet members the
situation is deteriorating
there are many factors to take into
account when considering how to best
tackle this issue
and these include the fact that the
number of properties which are now
available as airbnb has increased by
fifty percent over the last few years to
just over fifteen hundred
and also the fact that the number of
properties designated as empty and the
number of second homes each number just
over fifteen hundred that's a total of
nearly five thousand properties out of
circulation as permanent residences and
these numbers are being added to as more
and more new homes are being built
across thanat often on prime
agricultural land and bought as either
second homes or holiday lets
we need to consider more radical
solutions
which may include restricting all new
build and additional housing to be in
for full-time occupation and as a
primary residence
and also increasing the amount of
council tax
owners pay on second homes above the
current two hundred percent after five
years empty and three hundred percent
after ten
to consider these and other solutions
fully
would require input from agencies wider
than justice council
which is one reason why i urge you all
to adopt option 4.1 and agree to conduct
a full hearing where evidence can be
called from our mps and perhaps
government ministers to help us shape
our housing policies to better meet the
needs of all our residents especially
those facing increasing levels of
hardship
thank you
thank you very much council smith
thank you um
and thank you councillor whitehead for
raising this very important issue
not only important but urgent
um
i i don't have a lot of points to make
what i have is a couple of questions one
is um
how uh
close we believe to accurate the the
numbers in
um in the report are
and how severe the increase we think
has
has become in recent years as we've seen
steep inclines in
rents
and
the second at the risk of harping on
about housing development as i do um
what what scope
is there
for us to to
require
or
to
to place some kinds of time frames on
the developers that
could possibly be accused of land
banking
or
on the
developers who
achieve planning consent
on the promise of 30 and then rescind
that promise
thank you
there you go thank you
thank you councillor yates
thank you joe
um and i fully
and
follow what other counselors have said
here tonight and uh want to thank
council whitehead for this uh motion
which is
um a long time coming in my opinion um
so
rather than give my views i want to just
let you hear from some of the views of a
resident
in margate um my friend nikki she's 32
years old
born born here still lives here she is a
nurse and she's sent me a few words she
wants um
said here tonight um so she goes
having lived and worked in the local
community throughout my life i observed
i've observed firsthand that the
significant social and health issues
that rise from a lack of affordable
rental properties
the lack of affordable properties is
currently forcing rental prices up at an
uncontrollable rate
pricing residents out of their
communities
i have numerous friends and family who
recently had to leave the area seeking
more affordable rent leaving their
social networks families and careers
behind
the issue is further compounded by the
ever-increasing number of potential
long-term rental properties being used
for the sole purpose of holiday homes or
airbnbs which contributes very little to
the economy
professionally having worked in planet
within the historic and ongoing areas of
deprivation i have witnessed low-income
families having reduced options for
affordable rental properties
which has led to over occupancies over
occupancy of properties mental health
difficulties and further property and
further poverty
thank you for listening to that as well
the members is my view the members
should agree to debate the call for
action and conduct a full hearing
there truly is a housing emergency in
thanet
and this winter's imminent cost of
living crisis will only make the
situation much worse thank you
thank you very much
the lady at the back i'm sorry i didn't
catch your name i would have i would
imagine that yours would be such an
organization that might in the future
have been called to give advice on the
situation
but um given that you are here um would
you like to contribute
at this point do you have a few words
you'd like to say can i invite you then
to come to one of the microphones so
that we can hear you
and would you please be kind enough to
introduce yourself so that we can record
your name
uh in the minutes
thank you everybody i'm sarah ellis
sarah pangeli that was so hello to all
my former councillors um i was for town
clark in broad settings and peters and
had many happy years there
but i'm now a trustee of systems advice
in thanet
and as a bureau we're very concerned
with what is happening with housing at
the moment we're very keen to work with
the council
with whatever needs to be done
we do have case studies which we can
write up for the council to see
the kind of issues which come up over
and over again and i think this is what
is concerning us at the moment but it's
not just a case here and there it's
similar patterns of issues which need to
be dealt with
and i think tenants need more security
of tenure
tenants need to know that their rent is
not going to be increased dramatically
in a way that's not affordable at
exactly the same time that other costs
are soaring through the roof
those who do lose their homes need a
mechanism for
being helped into other accommodation
that is effective and meets their needs
at the time
and
we do have workers in the hospital who
are being told the only temporary
accommodation they can have is out of
area so that means that that clapping
that we did during the pandemic
needs to now be turned into action for
the people who work in our hospitals and
would be having to leave their jobs in
order to keep a roof over their heads
so thank you very much
thank you thank you
thank you
thank you chair
this administration is acutely aware
that the high cost of rental
accommodation in planet is causing
severe problems for some of our
residents and is committed to trying to
improve the situation
in addition to the excellent work being
done by our housing team
we have written to the minister of
housing calling for action
i quote from the letter
i call on the government to work with
local housing authorities across the
country to fund and support the
acquisition acquisition of land
and the construction of affordable homes
for rent
this will require significant increases
in the rates and availability of
affordable
housing capital grants reducing the need
to overstretch the business plans of
many registered providers and housing
revenue accounts and potentially new
definitions of land for affordable
housing purposes within the planning
system
this letter was sent in february of this
year and it was
initiated by the cabinet advisory group
who asked us to do this
it was disappointing that a response was
not received until july and didn't
really address our particular concerns
but
outline some government policies that
sought to address the problems which are
clearly experienced by councils
nationwide
councillor piper has already mentioned
the paper that which will be presented
to council in september
and then hopefully presented to the
government
i very much respect the work the housing
team is doing to address than its
current and future housing needs and
feel this course call for action does
not reflect the excellent work that they
do and the action they are already
engaged in and for that that reason is
inappropriate
thank you
thank you very much council baker
councillor whitehead would you like to
bring
your call for action formally then
to the
panel
firstly chair hope you're okay
and secondly thank you chair members of
ovue and scrutiny and everyone who has
contributed so far i know that this can
seem an odd way
of doing things but it's greatly
appreciated thank you
and
i'm slightly puzzled as to why this has
been deemed
to be a reflection on housing because if
anyone had read any of my submissions
you'll see that it is not at all
to do with our housing
provision
it is to do with the external bodies
that can help our housing provision i
have no point
in any of the papers either submitted
um
or the one i'm about to present actually
um criticized housing and what they do
with the limited funds available to them
so to the body of the call for action um
this process is i'm led to understand a
relatively unused procedure for us and
for many councils
and as such i want to do my best to make
sure that it functions well as we have
no direct procedural reference within
our overview and scrutiny protocol
this is a hugely important issue as i
know we are all aware of so i request to
be heard as fully as possible
and used as much as possible in terms of
questioning
i have directly requested to speak to
overview and scrutiny as part of the
ccfa and you will see that listed within
the submission
under
14.08 of the overview and scrutiny
procedure rules you can as a committee
ask me to answer questions and
contribute in relation to this issue
i request that you do so in order for
the
council a call for action to be explored
fully
everyone within the committee will have
received a document earlier today
including information relating to cancer
call for actions and why i've chosen to
bring one
i ask that you refer to this if
necessary and i'm happy to answer any
questions surrounding the submission
for a call for action to be accepted by
a council
the council must undergo a thorough
checking procedure
some of the evidence of which is in your
agenda packs
a councillor must prove that the issue
raised is what is termed an intractable
issue
that all standard procedures and
pathways available to them and to the
council have been tried and exhausted
an accepted call for action therefore is
proof in and of itself that we cannot
solve this via our internal processes
because all internal processes have
already been tried
offices are often limited in what they
can say publicly
professional discretion and a
determination to do the best possible
even in the worst circumstances means
that our political systems as they stand
place huge pressure on public and civil
servants
offices across the country and councils
across the country face an everyday
challenge of managing services with ever
decreasing funding
and simultaneously having to be seen to
manage these services well in order to
maintain both reputation and budgetary
responsibilities or risk losing further
funding in the future
this system creates a one-way dialogue
between local and central government
central government can insist that
everything is fine and that no further
funding or support is needed and
councils are forced to remain silent for
fear that speaking up in a way that
openly acknowledges both challenges and
needs will reflect badly upon them when
in fact there is no fault in needing
support from a system that should be
designed to maintain and build our
essential services
the role of politicians however is
different
and i have no such
limitation i can and will state publicly
that even with the hardest working team
and incredibly talented officers this
situation is unmanageable without
further central funding and support
i can and will state publicly that
another report and another letter or
another private conversation
won't solve anything because it hasn't
previously
i can and will state publicly that if we
have been shouting for funding and
support for years and have never
received it due to central policies that
do not prioritize councils being able to
build what they actually need then
another internal discussion on how to
make the best of what we have is not the
solution
we have a solution here it may not be
perfect
it may not be a magic wand to solve all
of our funding issues but it is a
mechanism that allows us as a council
and a scrutiny to do what our residents
would want and call for all external
partners link to our housing provision
to attend a full hearing where they can
see and hear the issues that we are
facing in a way that isn't simply
statistics and isn't simply words on
paper
i can say that at a time where residents
are now paying hundreds of pounds per
month for utilities
individuals cannot afford private
rentals that even at the lower end of
the market can now take up to over 80
percent of their income
but that doesn't convey the reality of
the local family evicted under a section
21 only to see their home remarketed
with a 400 pounds a month increase with
no way of re-entering the private market
as our lha rates are now wholly
insufficient
it doesn't convey the reality of the
single parent with a child with
additional needs settled in a specialist
educational placement whose only way
forward after a section 21 is to wait
until she is evicted accrue the costs
related to that in order for us to be
able to house her and her child away
from family support and school not
knowing whether the specialist placement
she fought so hard for will be available
when they return
and not knowing when they will be able
to return
it doesn't convey the reality of
residents who contact me sometimes daily
from all economic backgrounds to say
that they are broken
that they won't survive what is
happening to them and that they don't
want to survive what is happening to
them
it doesn't convey the reality of the
officers who work closely with these
residents every day who bear the impact
of the failings of systems that they
cannot control
who have to carry emotional burdens that
they should not have to shoulder
a counsellor call for action allows us
to call everyone related to this issue
to attend and be part of a public
hearing to address an issue that is
already beyond crisis
and will become incomprehensibly worse
as we approach winter and have even more
families unable to afford utilities food
and rent
it allows us to question the external
factors that limit us
it allows us to publicly address those
who can help and support us
it allows us to require answers
and more importantly it allows residents
to see that we are doing everything we
possibly can to support and help them
i ask you to choose a public hearing
i ask you to support option one because
put simply we have tried everything else
we have written every letter
we have contacted every minister
we have done everything that is
internally available
to stand any chance of weathering this
storm with our community still intact
and not scattered around the country we
have to have further external support
and funding
our delivery of affordable housing is
due to central legislation tied into the
delivery of private developments
if developers choose to build we can
require 30 affordable housing to be
delivered as part of larger developments
but this mode of delivery does not focus
on what we actually need in terms of
housing and the percentage of affordable
homes delivered is always at the mercy
of affordability tests
and the housing that we have to deliver
relying entirely on the whims of private
development and external markets makes
the entire system precarious
this is not something that we can tackle
or change on our own
we require support and change at a
central level and at the very least we
require those involved in the creation
and delivery of these policies to listen
to how they are actually working and see
the effects of them on our community
we need at least 548 affordable homes
per year to at least match current and
future demand
currently we are delivering 126 and we
hope to deliver 314 over the next year
but nearly all of this depends on
private investment and the perception of
profit within this area
this is not the way to deliver housing
that genuinely reflects need
we all know this
but those outside this crisis need to
know it and see it
the demographics of our area are stark
as the attached report indicates 29 of
our residents are classed as being on a
low income
hundred
below
15
eight pounds per year
we are in the bottom twenty percent of
the country in terms of average wages
and at the start of august we had one
thousand seven hundred and forty
households on our waiting list for
housing
as of june we had 184 families in
temporary accommodation
94 of those were out of area away from
support networks school and work
residents are relying on us
we can choose not to take this option
and continue to try everything that we
have tried before
but this allows us to do something
different and something that could
change everything and it allows us to
change it together cross-party
ccfas have a broad scope and i am asking
specifically for a full hearing so that
all aspects of the factors impacting on
housing supply can be considered
overview and scrutiny not only have the
ability to support the community through
doing this
but also to require particular
interventions from external parties as
part of the process
including but not limited to the right
to conduct public surveys hold public
meetings commission research and do all
other things that they reasonably
consider necessary to inform their
deliberations they may also ask
witnesses to attend to address them on
any matter under consideration
i am doing this because we have tried
everything but this approach
and i have gone to significant lengths
to show and prove that i have tried
everything possible over the course of
years before this point
i know that a full hearing will make a
difference
and regardless of outcome it will show
our residents that we are doing
everything possible to support
them i submit the council a call for
action to your scrutiny
and i am more than willing to answer any
questions or contribute in any way and i
ask members to invoke 14.08 of our
procedures so that you can do so
i thank you for your time and
consideration of something that is so
important to residents
and so important to all of us
and i would like to emphasize again as i
have done in everything submitted
that this is nothing to do
with our frankly excellent officers and
all of you in here councillors included
are very very aware that i will happily
bang the drum for housing forever and
would never impugn their efforts
thank
you you thank you councillor
until the chair comes back he's asked me
to uh
take over his vice chair um i can ask
bob bateford if he would like to take up
his option to speak under 20.1
i would love to but i was told by the
chairman i'm not allowed to as i'm a
cabinet member
unfortunately oh he just asked me to ask
you
if you wanted to speak before he left
the room
i mean be very simple i mean i'd just
like to ask councillor whitehead what
she actually thinks will happen as a
result of this
you know i mean we have tried everything
that
you know i think we've tried everything
we could do
um it's very difficult you know to get
government to move and i think
unfortunately the government has all
sorts of issues that it's grappling with
at the moment
um
and
from my point of view i mean i would
just love to know
what she thinks could be the outcome for
this because i fail to see that it's
going to be much different
um we could spend a lot of time talking
you can bring a lot of witnesses in but
you've made the point very eloquently
that you know we all agree with really i
mean we know this problem for people we
know that you know people to be moved
out of area is not good but at the end
of the day
now
we're doing the best that we can and
unfortunately external forces are
actually making it more and more
difficult and i'm not just not quite
sure what this process will do i
understand what you're trying to do but
i don't quite see how it's going to do
it thank you
thank you council both
john
i'll i'll let councillor papa take back
over
thank you very much i'm really sorry
about that
uh
that's okay i've got that thank you
um
please forgive me uh
councillor whitehead were you able to
complete
your comments i was are you okay jeff
thank you very much
yes i think
i might have whispered it too quietly
when i said could you invite bob porter
while i'm gone
i'm councillor whitehead mr porter would
you like to respond please
yeah or were you okay yeah so i'm
requesting under 14.0 to be able to
answer um if that's okay
and
i do understand your point entirely
but simultaneously i think
it's incredibly depressing
and frankly worrying that we're used to
not getting any response from central
government when we raise issues
that are intractable the whole point of
the institution of the counselor call
for action was so that
when we get to the end of a line on an
issue and that we are struggling to
solve it without external input
that as counsellors we can then
represent our community and say actually
we require you to hear what's happening
we require you to do this
those representatives can then choose to
not turn up they can choose not to
engage they can choose not to worry
about this
but it's our role as a council to
represent them
and regardless of the outcome and
regardless of whether they think it's
important
we have to show that it is important we
have to show that
the issues that we're facing here
need those
responsible for many of the policies to
actually come and deal with the reality
of it because we do deal with the
reality of it we are the ones who
receive the emails
the officers are the ones who deal every
day with residents
who if they are anything like the
residents who contact me are in
extraordinarily distressed states and
that is
not fair on housing it's not fair that
it is a continual one-way system
where we have to cope with whatever
happens
but never expect anything back and i
think we need to start expecting
something back
thank you
thank you very much councilman uh
i
again i apologize for the interruption
uh we need to turn now back to the
proper process
well thank you chair um i won't speak
for very long but just a couple of
things firstly uh thank you to
uh councillor whitehead and to
councillor bayford for comments about
the officers
of the council who do work extremely
hard to support
residents in the district in really
quite challenging circumstances and i i
do really appreciate those comments and
i and i will pass them on to the onto
the team
i know it means a lot to them
um secondly clearly it's a matter for
the um for the panel to decide um how
you would like to respond
to the call for action before you this
evening um
but i i would just like to confirm um
what uh counselor jill bae for informed
you about the beginning that we have
been working for some time
on a on a paper
with councillor bayford that's coming to
come to cabinet in september
looking at a whole range of issues
affecting housing delivery and
particularly of affordable housing
delivery um you know it is a um you know
a complex set of circumstances that of
that lead to the circum the position
that the district's in and that
people on low incomes in the district
particularly face
um
obviously that that works not uh
completed at this point and um
i haven't got all that information to
hand so i might not be able to answer
any detailed questions that you might
have this evening but i'm not sure
that's necessarily the purpose of this
evening's discussion
um but obviously if the if the panel
were to decide
that you wanted a more full discussion
at some point in the future we would be
able to prepare a paper for you to to
consider thank you
thank you very much
members
you've heard the
call for action statement from
councillor whitehead
you've heard
a response from
mr porter and also some response from
councillor bayford
we need to
decide as a panel
what we do now that we have heard these
major statements
we can as i mentioned earlier
decide to
have a full debate on the subject
and
see where we go from there as to what
recommendations
we would want to make
we can decide
to accept
the statement as it is
and move straight to a call for
the meeting that has been asked for
or thirdly we can decide
not to debate the matter any further
and at this point decide to take no
further
action
i'm just repeating those things again
for a couple of reasons not least
because the council is about to receive
a fairly fulsome report on the 22nd of
september
and we are not
beneficiaries of the contents of that
report
just yet
councilmania thank you for
the work that you have put in
to all of this clearly it is something
that is very close to your heart and
those of us who know you well
know that you wear your heart honestly
on your sleeve all of the time about all
of the things that you get involved in
it has clearly taken you
a lot of time
and a lot of effort
and those of us on the panel who have
received copies
of all the reports
and the
i use the word speeches very carefully
um when you've attended planning
or cabinet
overview and scrutiny you came here some
months ago to talk to us
so i think we are probably fairly well
aware
of
the concerns that you have been raising
and the manner in which you have
sought to raise them in the proper
manner at all times
one of the things the second reason i
mention this is because one of the
things
about a call for action which is
something that is
very unusual for all of us
is that it does say there must be a
reasonable expectation
that
this council senate district council can
produce
a solution
a call for action is generally
an action for a ward councillor as you
know i'm not going to preach to the
choir here you know exactly what it is
for a ward counsellor to bring an issue
that needs resolving
the implication is that that counselor
has used all due means and process that
was available
and
has not been satisfied not just as a
personal opinion but has not been
satisfied
the only example i could think of would
be and i hope the residents of buxton
road in ramsgate will forgive me but um
it is in my ward and if the bins had
been missed for six weeks out of seven
and regular contact had been made with
all the appropriate people within the
council and even
mentioned to the cabinet member with
responsibility for that area the bins
keep getting missed and if this went on
again over and over again for months and
months and months and nothing was being
done about it a call to action from a
ward member to this committee or another
part of council would allow that to be
investigated and it would therefore
produce a recommendation for action
i may have misunderstood you and i will
invite you to correct me if i have
but you seem to be
the resolution you are seeking is to
call for
outside bodies to come in and meet with
council it's not an actual resolution to
the problem
whereas a councillor called to action
over the bin situation at buxton road
might mean that
we
take a policy decision to send a smaller
vehicle down buxton road every thursday
and pick up every item of rubbish that's
been put out for collection yes it would
mess around with our recycling figures
but only on a small amount because it's
only one road that would have been a
fairly
straightforward a fairly simple
call for action this is clearly
not that
it's a lot more complicated
you have taken your concerns to
planning
and you have received
full
answers from the planning department in
so far as they are able to answer at
present
i remember
uh quite apart from seeing your your
paperwork for this
in terms of the
finance
briefings and meetings that we had where
the budget was discussed and and so on
you've taken your concerns notably about
the 549
thousand pounds
to the correct department you've also
been to cabinet with that and also
to full council
so
i guess
where i'm going with this is that you
have brought all of these issues
in the correct manner
to the correct departments
and as you've said yourself
the housing
group for example are doing everything
they possibly can
do
it would appear from all the
documentation that you have been
appropriately answered by each of the
council departments that you've been to
and each has answered
within their own sphere of expertise but
also
we must assume
departments talk to each other and so
they have answered together as a unit
this i think you will agree because you
mentioned it in your
uh talk that this is something that we
can't resolve on our own
but we have to be realistic it seems to
me we cannot instruct private companies
or private individuals on how they run
their business we can exercise our right
to voice our concerns
but we can't tell them how to run their
businesses and we can't tell builders
how to build and where to build
providing they follow
the proper processes that are in place
at the moment uh
overview and scrutiny exists
it seems to me and i'm very happy to be
corrected
if anybody has a better idea
it exists to improve
and enhance actions and decisions taken
by tdc
that come within the remit of tdc that
are the responsibility of tdc which
includes the allocation of financial
resources for the things that we deal
with
as you say this is not something that
can be resolved
simply by
tdc
it is not
a new problem or a new issue that has
come about because of
a war in the ukraine or the
energy crisis that we appear to be
about to face particularly during this
winter
so
i find
as
the chair of this committee and wanting
to do things
properly
so there is accountability for the
decisions that we make
i find myself as the chair of this
committee in a difficult position
i think everybody in this room
sympathizes with the views that you have
and
the actions that you would like to see
being taken
but given that we are talking about
finite resources and here mr porter will
know much more than me and mr blundell
will know much more than me we're
talking about finite resources here
how do we justify
what could be an extraordinary cost
to bring together private bodies which
won't come for free that's for sure
how do we justify spending the money
which would have to come from the
housing
budget because it's to do with housing
how do we justify spending that which
could be spent providing shelter for
those who need it the most when it is
extremely unlikely that we are going to
resolve the matter
clearly it requires in the case of tdc i
hope the leader won't mind me saying
the leader's got to
continue working very hard with
government and trying to persuade
government that this area much like jay
wick in essex this area needs additional
funding
i don't think there is anybody in this
room
that would disagree with your motives or
your reasoned argument for trying to do
something better
but
i guess i'm not going to make myself
very popular here and for that i do
apologize
um
it may be i'm the only person who's
disappointed by what i got to say i
don't know but i
do not think
that this
call to action
is appropriately dealt with
in this matter
it is not that you have asked questions
and they haven't been answered it is not
that you've asked questions and you've
not been satisfied by a full
response
it is that
you want more to be done
and i don't think anybody would argue
with that
the discussion is about
how it's done
we are asked to call for this formal
meeting
uh i have to say
and panel you are free to take your own
view
as your chair i would
i would be suggesting to this panel that
at this time
not least because we have a major report
coming from cabinet on the 22nd of
september
we resolve
not to take any further action
this evening
i don't make that suggestion from the
chair lightly
nevertheless it is one
that i offer to the panel
is there any member of the panel that
will be prepared to second that
cancer fellows thank you very much
members we can either do this by verbal
agreement or we can do it by show of
hands
um apologies if we're going under 14.0
you've asked me questions and i have the
right to come back
as there are some inaccuracies in what
you've said we are going under 14.1 as
you correctly mentioned which allows us
to bring outside organizations
in
at this stage we haven't done that at
this stage the panel is going to decide
whether or not to debate the motion as
it it's not a motion but the
subject that is before us so our first
decision is
do we wish to debate it we've heard from
you we've heard from mr porter we've
heard from
members who've spoken under rule 20.1
and the lady from citizens advice so
we've had a good deal of input
i want to avoid the danger of slipping
into a debate
before we have formally decided we will
debate the matter so the first question
to the panel
um i'm sorry chair but there are
inaccuracies in what you said and that
has just led the panel to a particular
conclusion
i will of course allow you to correct
inaccuracies
but i won't be able to if we go to
debate and it isn't allowed
so i believe this book to be able to
correct those actions
you can't debate you can't correct
my errors unless we are in debate then
i'm sorry you are not going to be able
to create
correct any errors i may have made
if on the other hand
you wish to correct an error you feel
i've made
prior
to this vote on whether or not to debate
the matter then i'm happy to hear
what you have to say thank you chair
um firstly
a counsellor call for action does not
only refer to tdc functions
um it's used not only to deal with
internal procedures if there's been no
resolution
but it's also used to bring in external
bodies external partners and external
organizations
so it's perfectly legitimate to call for
a call for action because you haven't
received responses that can actually
help from external bodies
in my case if you look through the
agenda you'll see that i have emailed
and written to ministers i have cc'd in
mps
and over the space of two years i have
had no response from central government
about any of these issues
so
it wouldn't be accurate to say that i
have had fulsome responses because i
haven't
and we are allowed to in fact the whole
point really of a call for action is
that we are allowed to call in external
bodies
in relation to the cost
you've mentioned that
you think that it would be particularly
costly to run this
effectively all it requires
is another hearing overview and scrutiny
so the cost would be emailing the
external bodies and organizations
and as you've mentioned there are
already significant reports in
preparation relating to housing so in
terms of officer time that's also
greatly reduced
this isn't an inappropriate request
in any way
this is a request to involve external
bodies because we have tried everything
internally
and i would like that to be considered
by the committee thank you
thank you very much uh i i know you're
there council huxley but we haven't got
to debate it so
[Music]
okay you saw cancer and i we wanted to
speak we raised our hands and then you
ignored us no i haven't ignored you we
haven't got to debate yet
you're asking a question you you can
only speak once the debate begins yeah
but you brought it you bought a proposal
i saw you just to let you know i'd seen
you yes yeah but you bought a proposal
to project
um the you know the the options to
vote against and we wanted to bring a
proposal to vote for another option so
you ignored us
i haven't ignored you i'm trying to deal
with
thank you very much councilwrighted for
your comments
when you
and i'm not suggesting you haven't read
it fulsomely because i'm sure you have
what i said was each department you've
taken it to
at tdc
within tdc's remit you have been given
the time to make your case you have been
given answers that have been fulsome and
well prepared
i didn't mention answers from government
or anybody else for that matter
but following the advice
that we get from wheresoever we get it
as a council and that includes of course
outside bodies tdc in order for this to
be a call to action my reading of it is
that tdc
must be able to appropriately resolve
the matter
and we can't it is not a matter that we
can resolve on our own
i am quite happy to be corrected if my
reading and understanding of that is
wrong and i know you're going to tell me
it's wrong but
i would ask you at another time to check
those facts with
um
with our
democratic services department
we
cannot resolve this on our own you are
quite right you've said three times now
we can invite people in that still
doesn't mean we're going to resolve it
on our own
does it it just means we're going to
receive more information
and there are many different ways of
sharing the information that we have
and of receiving information from other
people rather than a formal
meeting
one more go
thank you chair
it isn't the case that a call for action
has to
require
the issue to be solved directly by tdc
because otherwise the call for action
itself would not allow for the
involvement of external agencies because
they wouldn't be relevant
we have to have a reasonable expectation
that we can do something
and that something can simply be a
public hearing that can be the thing
we don't have to expect that we are able
to solve it we don't have to expect that
we are able to solve it on our own
because we can't that's the whole point
of doing this
but we do have to believe that we have
exhausted every other option
and i think if you look at the agenda
pack it is very clear that we have
exhausted every other option
we can't do this on our own but what we
can do is call for a public hearing and
invite those who can help us to solve it
and that is the point of a counsellor
call for action
and i thank you for allowing me to come
back
council writer that's absolutely fine
a point 11
as with all scrutiny does this matter
refer to have the potential for scrutiny
to produce recommendations which could
realistically be implemented and lead to
improvements
therefore we know
that we can receive from all sorts of
different organizations the ladies spoke
earlier about some of the difficulties
and we can implement some of them
but we can't resolve the matter
which is what the call to action is
you're simply calling it seems to me for
a meeting to discuss the matter again
and we have it has been
it has been discussed
over and over and over again
as the chair of this committee i do not
think
not least because there is a report due
to come to council very shortly i do not
think at this time it doesn't mean you
can never
call for a public meeting i do not think
at this time this is the appropriate
time for this panel
to call for the external meeting
so i'm going to make some people very
unhappy i realize that
including some of my colleagues on the
panel but
my recommendation to the panel
is that at this time we take no further
action which includes
not debating the subject we have before
us
it's been seconded
can i have a show of hands for not
debating i don't think this is fair
counselor austin and i wanted put to
propose
well i don't want to put words in your
proposal 4.1 i want to propose option
4.1 you looked at me and at cancer
austin and you ignored us and i got in
first so we should hear my option first
you can you can choose yeah
to ask to speak and i was going to bring
up option 4.1
so why can't we vote on that first it's
unfair you're not treating us all fairly
you looked straight at me and then you
went to
your own option and to be honest
you know you your referee in this
process you are the chair you shouldn't
be giving a 20-minute speech about what
you think it's not appropriate
thank you i think it is
sometimes when the chairman of any
committee needs to draw things together
they do have to do so in a coherent
manner and in a manner which is fair and
equitable to all 4.1 says the panel
could opt to debate the call for action
request and agree to conduct a full
hearing
what i have suggested is that we do not
do that if you wish to propose that we
do debate it
is that a proposal yes
thank you thank you
seconded by
councilwoman
in the order in which these
recommendations are made going to have a
show of hands for not
absolutely yes
we have to take
we have to take a vote on whether or not
to have a recorded vote
can i have a show of hands please to
take a recorded vote
okay thank you very much
do you want some water no no it's going
to save those against the abstentions
those against
any abstentions
thank you
there is a recording there will be a
recorded vote
yes the vote was not to debate the
motion would you please would you do
that to get home
debate the motion
or
debate
no
[Music]
at this point then i'm going to hand
over to mr hughes to conduct the
recorded vote for the proposals that are
before us
[Music]
thank you chairman so just to be clear
you're either going to be voting for the
motion proposed by councillor um
piper so which is not to debate the
motion or you're going to be voting for
the
uh proposal made by councillor huxley
which is to delay the motion okay let's
just make that clear okay
no it's it's it's an either or
vote so you're either voting to debate
it to debate it or not to debate it okay
yeah so everybody
okay
so any meeting i've been in this council
at ramsey town council um it's always
the uh the person who puts her hand out
first
you know it says i want to
i propose option 4.1 and we vote on that
first so any other
options that anyone else wants to go
through that's not what happens here
that happens all the time at full
council meetings wherever you either
vote for one or you vote for the other
like with the chairman live with the
vote i just like to complain about the
process because the chair ignored my
hand up
i wanted to speak and i wanted to go for
option 4.1 so to be fair to be fair
council actually obviously we don't want
to
play tennis with issue this issue all
evening to be fair
i nodded that i had seen you i had no
idea what you wanted and it wasn't the
time for me to go to the panel
for points questions or debate
so i had simply noted and i've written
down on my paperwork here that if there
was to be a debate we would go to
councillor huxley first so i hadn't
missed you i hadn't ignored you it
wasn't the right you went straight to
your option
so you ignored what you knew i was going
to say i'm sorry i don't i have no idea
what you're going to say
but you brought your option out first
before you knew that cancer austin and i
wanted to speak
i had no idea what you were going to say
mr hughes
so
do you want to
raise the points of order or not i don't
know whether or not you want to continue
cancer keen is it point of order
yeah well it's just a point of
clarification really because i'm not
quite understanding the vote so if we're
putting both options at the same time
how do we vote for or against one sorry
i'm just not clear what i'm doing
so one of the options
on the table is to not debate the motion
but it's not to debate the ccff and and
so it ceases and the other option which
is the one that councillor huxley has
put forward is to to debate the motion
and then
no we don't want to do anything with
this or yes we do want to do something
with it
ask for some clarification so
councillor whitehead obviously spoke we
had people in the in the public gallery
including councillors speak
and then the chair introduces a whole
different aspect to this
and yet i feel
impotent because i have been sat here
unable to pass any comment on what the
chair has made and i actually find that
undemocratic it might be that that
protocols have been followed but i find
it utterly undemocratic that the chair
is then able to speak for 20 minutes
suggesting we do something which isn't
even an option
if i can respond to that the
first my first job as the chair
was to share with the panel again just
in case
the technical manner in which we would
do this
to point out that we had already heard
that there is a substantial report
coming to council on the 22nd of
september that's not the sole reason but
that is a good enough reason for me as
the chair to say at this point
i don't think we gain anything by taking
this any further
at this point
so am i now allowed to challenge that
opinion
is that it's do we have a debate about
that opinion no
we're going to do i understand for mr
hughes is we're going to invite
all those
in favor
of not debating the motion
to show of hands all those in favor of
debating the motion to share our hands
is that well fired recorded it's
recorded
recorded vote
yes
yeah and obviously at the end of that
process
that there will be a majority one way or
the other and if that is to debate the
motion then we will start a debate and
we will have a debate about it
yeah okay so is it is are you happy for
me to conduct please
okay so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to go across
let me just go back to the beginning
and
charlo's on the line you need to write
it down
you're going to rely on me to write it
down no chance
that's it
so
councillor huxley would you like to
debate the motion or not to debate the
motion
i'd like to debate the motion
okay for a call to action and agree to
conduct a full hearing into the agreed
future panel meeting thank you
uh councillor pat moore
[Music]
i can't remember what she said but i
agree with her
okay
i'll put that down as a yes for debate
councillor lee's
not to debate okay uh councillor boyd
not to debate
okay councillor paul more
not debate
councillor linda wright
not to debate
council of fellows uh not to debate
councillor keane
to debate
councillor curry
councillor wing two debates
council austin
uh councillor tomlington
not to debate uh councillor coleman cook
not to debate
and councillor piper
okay
we'll just take all those up
so the result of that is eight six in
favor of not debating the motion not
waiting the ccff
comments to make regarding our
work program as it stands at the moment
council fellows i just want to ask our
counselor carrie if we had many
responses back to our current
working review party that we've got
um the situation at the moment um for
all members um the um
the panel set up the working party on
the 26th of may on the 7th of july we we
met and agreed
an approach to hold
separate sessions to gather evidence
from town council representatives
td officers and cabinet members and
possibly uh the leader so
that's the situation at the moment
thank you thank you
councillors did i just add on the matter
of effective working with town and
parish councils how grateful we are that
ramsgate town councillors were invited
to the recent members briefing on the
levelling up fund and that type of
approach is is really constructive and
helpful and
much welcomed by the town councils thank
you
i think it was i i personally i was
hoping that one or two more might be
there being as it was specifically for
them but yeah it's a it's a good point
it's a a good start
report list
unless there is something from the plan
that the panel will wish to consider we
are again asked to note the report
okay
thank you very much everybody that
concludes the business for tonight's
meeting and i declare this meeting
closed at
8
38.